MARTIN GIRARD, porte-parole,
Transports Québec
on prépare le tunnel là pour
l'entrave majeure à compter
du 31 octobre. On est dans
le tunnel qui va servir
- Le tunnel Louis-Hyppolite-La
Fontaine, en direction de
Montréal, se met en mode travaux
majeurs. Le compte à rebours est
la circulation sera plus
restreinte que jam
Seulement deux voies en
direction de Montréal et
seront ouvertes.
- Sur lea avoir
des flèches. L'objectif de
ces flèches-là, c'est de faire
une distance plus importante
entre chaque véhicaque véhicaqu.
- La recommandation sera
de 30 mètres de distance
correspondra à la distance
flèches peintes au sol.
Et comme d'habitude, il faudra
allumez les phares du véhicu
ça va être des anti-éblouissemer
le contresens des phares des
véhicules; donc pour réduireébl,
là, des conducteurs.
Ces éléments-là ont été mis
en place.
- Selon Transportsnnuellement ue
d'incidents dans le tunnel
Louis-Hyppolite-La Fontaine
dernière, de ce nombre, trois
ont causé des ince
PATRICK GALLAGHER, conseiller
sécu. incendie Ren. La Fontaine
Fontaine est muni de cabinets
incendie, donc un au
à l'intérieur même du tunnel
auquel les pompiers vont se
les cabinets incendies.
- Des pompiers, dédiés à la
sécurité du tunnel sont en paven
équipement spécialisé, tant pou.
- C'est  électriques
qui sont situées à l'intérieur
du corridor d'évacuation, dans
place et se dirigent, là, selon
la situaendroit à
l'intérieur du tunnel.
- Des véhicules adaptés
aux déplacements efficaces
dans un corridor.
- La particularité du véhicule,
conduites aux deux extrémités
parce qu'on se retrouve bien
entendu dans un corridor,
donc quand ça vient le temps
très évident et c'est toujours
tion de temps.
de cet axe routier névralgique
dans la région méteeeeee
sont prévus s'échelonner
sur trois ans.- Donc, - Donc, -t
vraiment regarder leurs options
et changer la façoen transpoen t
collectif, soit en quittant plue
davantage de télétravail,
voir quelles sont  permettre
de faciliter leur vie.
en y intégrant une bonne